so ganz was anderes meine damen und
herren die grünen hatten gerade eine
idee
schwarzfahren soll in deutschland keine
straftat mehr sein sondern nur noch eine
ordnungswidrigkeit
ja dabei ist knast manchmal besser als
bus
mehr platz und ältere leute tatsächlich
tatsächlich entdeckt die groko gerade
den öffentlichen nahverkehr wegen dieser
krise und so überfällig was leistet in
unser verkehrssektor eigentlich in
sachen co2 reduktion wollen die
klimaziele 2030 einheiten das heißt im
verkehr 42 prozent reduktion von 1990
bis heute 0 reduktion 29 jahren 0
reduktion
was sagt man dazu ganz genau
aber jetzt jetzt bringt der pnv die
rettung schließlich hat die groko jahr
2017 ihr sogenanntes sofortprogramm für
saubere luft gestartet 1,5 milliarden
euro in fünf deutschen modell städten
gibt es immerhin ja ermäßigte
nahverkehrstickets und wenn mal jemand
radikalere ideen hat passiert dass hier
nicht von uns bearbeitet
die linke will öffentlichen nahverkehr
für alle und zwar in guter qualität
barrierefrei und bezahlbar am besten zum
nulltarif
erstens sie haben der katastrophe lachen
war natürlich an die scheuer
ja gut kostenloser nahverkehr da kann
man darüber streiten ich habe mal
pünktlicher und sauberer nahverkehr
würde es schon reichen
viele bahnen haben 30 jahre oder mehr
auf dem buckel
die folge kennen sie ausfälle
überfüllung ersatzverkehr
da ist es jeden morgen für tausende
deutsche pendler nicht gepasst and the
fury ist sondern wir fast pünktlich ende
juni und zwar zu recht für ios plus das
ganze chaos zwischen den vielen
unterschiedlichen verkehrsbetrieben
gucken sie mal was passiert wenn die
düsseldorfer rheinbahn 43 neue züge
gekauft ohne sich vorher mit duisburg
abzusprechen
bei der testfahrt vor wenigen wochen
schrammte ein prototyp dann hier im
benachbarten duisburg am bahnsteig
entlang
die düsseldorfer rheinbahn musste
zugeben sie habe schlicht vergessen dass
in duisburg einige bahnsteige breiter
sind da passiert was hier noch breiter
ist die bahnsteige sind in duisburg und
die fahrgäste ist nun mal eine frau es
muss viel mehr investiert werden im
öffentlichen nahverkehr vielmehr und
wenn sie darüber meckern jedes einzelne
auto verursacht pro jahr auch 2100 euro
und zwar ungedeckte kosten für
umweltbelastungen lärm luftverschmutzung
unfälle
das zahlen alle übrigens auch
fahrradfahrer vor allem muss aber auf
dem land endlich mal was passieren wo
fast gar nichts geht in sachen
öffentlicher nahverkehr
wir brauchen innovative pnv ideen fürs
dorf hier zum beispiel die
verkehrsträger app sie zeigt er am wohl
der nächste tracker ist der sich in die
stadt bringen der traktor kann aber auch
dein elektroauto ziehen dass du nicht
leiden konnte ist weil es auf dem land
keine einzige ladesäule
außerdem kriegt jeder bushaltestelle
bald eine eigene digitale anzeigetafel
untersteht den ganzen tag hier fährt nie
ein bus und wenn es mal ganz eilig ist
freunde gibt es ja immer noch couceiro
schnapp dir irgendeinem grund 3000 hause
sind
der öffentliche nahverkehr da muss man
ansetzen ich sage ihnen solange die
politik und zwar in bund und ländern
nicht wirklich mehr tut für den
nahverkehr bleibt jede fahrt ein
abenteuer
vor allem im berufsverkehr hier dennis
knossalla stellt sich der challenge
jetzt bei dmax vergiss die
krabbenfischer aus alaska lacht sich
kaputt über ice road truckers die
ultimative herausforderung für echte
kerle heißt mit bus und bahn durch nrw
alle meine freunde haben gesagt ich
spinne aber ich ziehe das durch
ich versuche von dick nach kamp-lintfort
zu kommen und zwar mit öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln und jetzt kommt in nur
fünf tagen hat die pflicht sie die ein
ticket aber vorsicht für welchen tarif
bereich mit preisstufe 3 darf das
gesamte art tarifgebiet befahren werden
sofern sich die preisstufe 3 nicht aus
einer tarif grenzüberschreitenden vater
relation ein versuch diese scheiße zu
kapieren
während hinter dir ein wütender mob
wartet
die busfahrt nach recklinghausen
geschafft und jetzt sage ich hey moment
die regionalbahn nach duisburg kommen
die bahn hat technische probleme und
sind sie erstmal fest muss aufpassen
dass ich nicht dehydriert tag 2 die
regionalbahn richtung duisburg tag 3
dennis knossalla hat sich mit cholera
und gelbfieber etc
außerdem wurde sein rucksack geklaut tag
noch dennis knossalla hat schon viel
erlebt aber bus fahren bringt ihn an
seine grenzen
verzeihung müssten sie hier drin eier
essen
die fahrausweise bitte wissen die
lustige geschichte also ich trägerin
eine doku für dmax ja und wir haben sie
den rucksack klauen und so wurde das
kloster zu einem rund 7000 schwarzfahrer
wie in deutschland aktuellen aufsitzen
kamp lintfort hat er nie erreicht
seit jahrzehnten
deutsche städte nur nach den
bedürfnissen von autofahrern gebaut ist
das problem übrigens die kommission für
mehr klimaschutz im verkehr hat diese
woche einen ersten entwurf ihres
abschlussberichtes vorgelegt und darin
kommt das wort das werden sie nie
glauben tempolimit jetzt nur noch als
fußnote vor
wer hätte das gedacht reden wir drüber
mit einer frau der geschwindigkeit schon
aus genetischen gründen suspekt ist denn
sie kommt aus der schweiz
kein wunder wenn
ja
aber jenseits aller drogen schweizer
wird zur hesl es gibt da schon ein
mentalitätsunterschied gerade auf der
autobahn oder ja also auf der schweizer
autobahn davon halt einfach maximal 120
fahren und wenn man drei zu schnell ist
dann muss man so viel zahlen wie ein
haus in mecklenburg vorpommern kosten
ist jetzt nicht so mega viel aber schon
ein bisschen viel und in deutschland
darf man zu großen teilen einfach machen
was man will wie in einem computerspiel
aber man weiß halt du hast nur ein leben
auf der schweizer autobahn ist alles in
so einem strengen korsett aus regeln und
die deutsche autobahn ist er wie so eine
alleinerziehende frustrierte übermüdete
mutter von acht kindern die einmal im
jahr mit ihnen in den freizeitpark fährt
in europa park in rust
sie haben morgens um neun aus dem auto
lässt und ihnen hinterher schreibt um 18
uhr treffen wir uns auf parkplatz es
welt kommt wird nicht mitgenommen
und insgeheim freut sie sich bei der
vorstellung ist vielleicht zwei oder 30
ja ich war auch autobahn so extrem ist
es auch wieder nicht bei uns doch also
jeden morgen werden in deutschland die
leute auf die autobahn geschickt wo man
sagt fahrt war zu schnell ihr könnt und
alle fahren so schnell sie können dann
der spitze sind dann meist ein mercedes
aus der nähe von stuttgart und ein audi
aus der nähe von münchen die sich an
rennen liefern mit knapp 300 km/h tätig
kollidieren und für einen unfall sorgen
der dann wiederum dafür sorgt dass stau
herrscht der dann wiederum dafür sorgt
dass alle anderen auf der autobahn nicht
so schnell fahren können wie sie gerne
würden und das rettet ihnen das leben
das heißt es werden einfach jeden morgen
zwei leute für die götter der deutschen
autobahn geopfert
und in der schweiz haben wir einfach
nicht genügend leute um sowas zu machen
wo ich gerade hier hat schweizerin was
sagst du so geplanten großen fusionen
deutsche bank und commerzbank deutsche
bank weiß ich jetzt nicht aber ich war
schon mal in einer deutschen bank weil
ich wohne zur hälfte der zeit in
deutschland und zur anderen hälfte in
der schweiz ist was die steuerbehörde
zuschauer ich wurde zu 60 prozent der
zeit in der schweiz
und dann dachte ich ich gebe mal eine
deutsche bank war eine deutsche bank ist
wie so eine übungs bank für eine
richtige bank wobei der vergleich mit
der schweiz ist jetzt nicht ganz fair
weil unsere banken hatten ja nach dem
krieg durch ominöse umstände plötzlich
irgendwie recht viel gold das wohl zum
teil vorher mal in deutschland war es
egal also schweizer banken sind auf
jeden fall total einschüchtern man kommt
rein alles ist aus marmor der boden die
wände sind aus marmor die pflanzen die
angestellten alles ausmachen
es werden einem sachen angeboten die man
nicht versteht da du four ristretto und
eine deutsche bank ist mehr so wie ein
jugendzentrum da steht ja noch so eine
gespendete couch roben und man denkt
sich ja hätte man auch entsorgen können
aber es
es liebt dass die mutter von dennis tito
jackson noch vor allem franck ist ein
fleck drauf wer sich bewegt ja
interessant ich weiß immer nicht was mir
lieber ist wenn die bank viel schöner
ist als die wohnung die ich mir von
ihrem geld gerne kaufen würde oder wenn
sie viel schäbiger ist weil wenn die
bank total pumpels ist dann heißt das ja
dass sie ihren kunden zu viel geld
wegnimmt aber wenn die bank
heruntergekommen ist dann weiß man nicht
ob die leute dort überhaupt mit geld
umgehen können also grundsätzlich dürfen
die dort natürlich von mir aus gerne
fusionieren ich sage immer jeder
deutsche banker der im büro mit einer
fusion beschäftigt ist ist ein raser
weniger auf der deutschen auf leader
basel programm
mein arzt hat mir verboten mich
weiterhin so aufzuregen
deswegen wollte ich euch allen einfach
nur einen schönen tag wünscht überall
lassen ihre techniken liegen
und hier lastet das xenix ein
beschissenes ab oder
[Musik]